Bruce Lee was wildly popular. I started
watching these movies and practicing
kicks. My journey in martial arts
extended over 35 years. My instructor,
he would have a broadsword. He would
grab it with his hand and slowly raise
his hand up the sword and then he'd open
his hand. No cut, no bleeding, nothing.
That's not possible. You can even touch
it without being sliced. I asked, "What
was that?" He said there was a a story.
This was when I first started my martial
arts journey, age of nine. Um and I
started in uh taekwondo learning a
little bit of hapkido.
Very excited about what I was learning.
But I remember my instructor, he was a
Korean soldier. He taught troops in the
Korean War. So the way he taught us was
very militaristic.
and he would do these feats of strength
in front of our eyes that were
incredible. One in particular was he
would have a broadsword.
>> Okay.
>> And he would take a piece of paper and
wipe it across the sword both ways and
it would slice it. It was that sharp.
>> Mhm.
>> Then at the bottom of the sword, top of
the hilt, he would grab it with his
hand, tie a belt around it. one black
belt on one end, another black belt on
the other, pulling to tighten it. And
then what he would do would be to
concentrate and slowly raise his hand up
the sword. Took him about five minutes
until he got all the way to the top and
then he'd open his hand. No cut, no
bleeding, nothing.
>> Wow. And when I saw that, now me not
knowing anything about the Bible or the
supernatural, I believed what I was
taught. I believed that that was power
that you can build from within.
>> As you advanced through the ranks,
>> so it made me want to advance through
the ranks in order to gain that power.
That was just one of the many feats that
he would do, but that was something that
drew me further in and fueled my
training. I think that's fascinating
because you see something very similar
in witchcraft and something that appeals
to people through movies and TV and
Hollywood. They see the access to that
kind of power. You know, I remember when
I was training, I was probably,
I don't know, two, three years into my
martial arts training. And you could say
martial arts cinema went through phases.
Kung fu movies were kind of like B- rate
in the corner, like not mainstream.
>> The Matrix comes out and he says this
line, I know kung fu.
>> I know kung fu. And it kind of put kung
fu into the forefront of mainstream
Hollywood media, people's eyes, faces,
because before that time it was like
heavily like karate was like that was
the thing. I mean karate kid, right? All
of all of that was in the in the
forefront.
>> And in that moment when you're training
in that discipline, it becomes like a
sense of pride. like what you're doing
is being put before everybody's eyes,
you know, it's the same kind of thing
and and you really identify with that.
And of course, when the film is done,
you're like amped, you're energized, you
just want to go train, you want to work
out, you want to put your skills to the
test. But just like in witchcraft,
martial arts gives you this sense of
power
>> and identity. an identity and and it's
it's all about you
>> and and God is essentially cut out of
the equation.
>> So, wait, when your dad was doing this,
um did did did you ever question as a
kid like how's that even possible? Like
>> that that was Oh, that was your
instructor that was doing.
>> So, I I did ask how it was possible. I
mean, I didn't understand it. How do you
do something like that? We saw that
sword. We knew it was sharp.
>> We knew there was no way on earth
>> you could grab that.
>> You can grab You can even touch it
without being sliced. But he he grabs it
and then
>> has the the fist tightened with the belt
tight pulled around it.
>> Yeah.
>> Two black belts pulling on each end. I
mean really and then he raises it.
>> That's not possible.
>> Right.
>> But not having a spiritual or biblical
foundation.
I asked what was that? He said it was
the power that you already have, but
it's not developed.
And I didn't have anyone to tell me that
that wasn't true.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I believed it. And I figured that if
I stay long enough and I train hard
enough,
>> I'll develop that same power.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. That's the hook, huh?
>> Yeah. It's like when I'm when I'm
listening to this, I'm just like and I
know Keith is going through it's like we
remember that and it's like even though
it have may have a different face or
have a different covering, it's the same
thing every time. It's the carrot.
>> And it's different for different people.
So for me, I was I was like small. Like
I was a small kid. By the time I was
ending my freshman year of high school,
I was still only about
and probably
not even 100 pounds.
>> Wow.
>> And it was, you know, is that next year
I grew. when you're that small kid and
I'm still like the newer kid in my
class, you know, I'm the newest kid
>> since grade, you know, you go through
sixth grade, you're getting into junior
high, you know, you're still that kid
that's moved.
>> What do you What do you want? You want
people to not pick on you.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah.
>> You want to not be shoved around. You
want to not be the target of people's,
you know, bumping you into the lockers,
that kind of stuff. Mhm.
>> And when I did start my martial arts
training and people knew that was going
on, that started to back off,
>> you know, they and of course I was
growing too. So it was like that whole
combination of that. It puts you in the
seat of don't mess with me,
>> you know, and and you as a human being,
you just appreciate that you're getting
you're getting something out of it. You
feel more in in control and you're
seeing the different things happening.
And so I remember like my reflexes
started changing my balance everything.
It's not that you know having good
balance isn't that's that's a good
thing. There are there are positive
things that can come with it because
they're physical in nature. So I
remember one time very distinctly I'm in
the lunch line at school and we have
these trays and of course your your
fork, your spoon, your knife is all like
wrapped up in a napkin. mine gets bumped
and they all come out and just without
thinking just snatch it.
>> I mean, out of midair. You're just like,
where does that, you know, where does
that come from? It's just
>> Yeah,
>> it just happens.
>> And you can attribute a lot of that
stuff to, you know, reflex,
coordination, all that. But, you know,
there's there's a lot of stuff that that
comes with it that's it's just not
natural. I remember the the first and I
hate to say grandmaster, but that's what
they called him.
>> Um, the first one that I trained under,
I remember him telling a story and I I
think I was maybe like a green belt when
he told this, but he he was asked in in
this circle of other, you know, higher
level green belt, brown belts about
events that had happened in his life
that were that showed this thing that he
called this internal power, this chi
energy. And he said he was working at a
place called Eastman, Kodak Eastman in
the factory. And he said one one day he
said everybody there knew he's a Vietnam
vet. He was a Green Beret and um they
knew about the martial arts and
everything and a lot of the guys just
didn't like it because you know they're
thinking who do you think you are? You
know, give me a break. And he said he
was walking through this huge corridor
in the factory, you know, multiple
stories up. And he said as he was
walking, he said back 50 feet behind
him, one of the guys that did not like
him stepped out. And he said, "I'm
walking away from the guy." He said, "I
didn't even see him." But this guy
stepped out and he had a huge wrench and
he said he took that wrench and threw it
at him. He's not even seeing it. He said
all of a sudden, he said his hand went
up and he grabbed the wrench in the air
and he just kept right on walking. He
didn't see it. He didn't see the guy
step out.
That's not you doing that. And like like
Keith said, there are some, you know,
you train something for a while, it's
like woohoo, you know, it's like it it's
just physical. But then there's this
other thing that's not simply physical.
And every single art that I trained in,
and I'm sure you as well, and Keith as
well, that winds up being the goal,
>> not just the physical. Because I mean I
know for for a fact
I could do 200 push-ups, you know, in a
row. Okay, fine.
>> What do you do when you're 65 years old
and you're still doing 200 push-ups?
Maybe it's like Jun Ree or something,
you know, where you're in the
>> But there comes a point where you can't
go any farther physically.
>> You know, you can run 8 miles or 12
miles a day every day of your life.
You're never going to run 70 miles an
hour. In order to go past that physical
point, there has to be supernatural.
Yeah. Something.
>> Yeah.
>> So, Christian,
>> yes.
>> Um, by now our audience has gathered you
spent some time in the martial arts like
Eric, like myself. How long was that?
And what what disciplines did you study?
And and
>> yeah, I'm very interested.
>> Also, let's let's find out what that
journey was like because that's in your
past now.
>> Yes. Um, well, I started at the age of
nine and like everyone right around that
that time in the
>> early 70s, late 60s, early 70s, Bruce
Lee was wildly popular.
>> Mhm.
>> And so, me being small like yourself,
um,
>> I come from a family of eight, uh, five
boys, three girls. I'm the youngest of
the five boys. Well, my father was a
boxer.
>> Okay.
He taught all of his sons except me how
to box.
>> And I remember being a child asking him
to teach me. And at that point, dad had
reached a point where he thought that
violence was reprehensible.
>> And so he refused to teach me. Now, it
was a good thing, but not to me at the
time.
>> I'm like, "Wait a minute. You taught all
of my brothers and you have and I'm
getting picked on and you won't show me
how." So I started watching these movies
and practicing kicks and my mother would
get complaints at school that I was
practicing kicks on other students. I
didn't know how to do it right. So she
thought it'd be a good idea that I got
some discipline. So she found a
taekwondo school and said, "Hey, you
need to go here."
>> So that was the start of my journey
wanting to be like Bruce Lee, wanting to
be strong because he was small but he
was strong, fast, he was powerful. Um my
journey in martial arts extended over 35
years.
>> Wow.
>> So my base was taekwondo and hikido.
>> Um
>> as I trained I had the misfortune of
having great instructors but a lot of
times great instructors don't hang
around.
>> They move around quite a bit. So when I
lost my taekwondo instructor, I just
continued training that style until I
got to college. Just all the basics. Um
when I got to college, I started
taekwondo again, but I realized um I
fought in a tournament called S. Henry
Cho uh national championships in Madison
Square Garden. I was a green belt at the
time and I won that tournament and I was
getting accolades. I had a little
article written up on me in uh at Duke
University where I went to school.
>> And people didn't realize that was the
most insecure I ever felt about my
abilities because I felt I won so easily
using primarily just my legs. I was very
good with my legs,
>> not as good with my hands.
>> And I did research and found that wow,
in Chicago, a new Wing Chun Kung Fu
school had opened up probably my
sophomore year, junior year college. So
during the summers I would go there to
train and develop my hands really well
over the next few years. But then I
started trying to test out what I what I
learned. I wanted to know how practical
it was. I had a friend who was a
wrestler who take me down and twist me
into knots. And I said I need to learn
something that's going to help me with
joint locking to neutralize what he's
doing.
>> So I started studying uh no tai jutsu
and you um and achieve second degree
black belt status in that. But I was
experimenting with other people I knew
who knew different art forms. So started
training a little jundo, a little boxing
>> and um then eventually moved into
Brazilian jiu-jitsu. Did some of that
training
>> and then eventually into some MMA
training to test the realism of it,
>> right? Um, so over the course of 35
years, I would train extremely hard and
I wasn't afraid to test what I learned
with people who were willing to do it in
a friendly manner, but physical.
>> Um,
I think it was in my mid to late 40s,
I started having conflicts because it
had become an idol to me. Um, people
always believed that I was a natural,
that I picked up techniques very
quickly, but they didn't understand that
I would obsess over techniques. I would
watch the videos and movies and analyze,
dream about it, think about it, and I
would practice it, and I would get
people to let me practice on them. um
study massage therapy so that I could
learn the the and an anatomy so I could
learn the connection of the bones, the
tendons, the nerve pathways so that I
could create combinations to strike.
>> Um
but as I became more spiritually mature,
it was a conflict that arose in my mind.
Why am I always looking at guys,
especially bigger than I just see them
and I'm always sizing them up.
>> Yeah.
>> And that guy Yeah. It's like if he were
to do something, this is what I'd do.
All right. This is how I'd approach him.
>> And you're looking for weaknesses and
this is what I
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. I know. And I hated that. I hated
it.
>> And I was wondering, wait a minute. One
time really cool guy I met, but I'm
sizing him up. And I'm thinking, why am
I thinking like this instead of trying
to get to know this guy?
>> Yeah.
>> And and bring Christ to him.
>> Yeah. And that's when the conflict came.
And I realized for me the most damaging
thing that the martial arts did for me
was the mental framework.
>> I had a framework that worked at odds
with the mission to go out and bring the
gospel to the world. And that's when the
conflict started.
>> Yeah. You know, it's weird weird for me
because like the and I didn't see this
until probably right at the end
>> and even after the year or so afterward,
it was like everything that I realized
that I had been taught, you know, even
though I wasn't in it as long as you,
>> it all had one word, self.
>> It was it was all self. It was
selfdefense, selfesteem,
self-confidence, self. And I didn't
realize that spirit of self had it it
poured out all over my family and every
other part of my life.
>> And I was like, man, I just don't I
didn't realize, you know, I didn't want
that.
>> It's like when I remember when God set
me free, it was like, man, I can I can
just be a human being. I mean, I I can
get hit. I can trip and fall and it's
okay. I don't have to I don't have to be
something. And it's like, I can just be
a human being. It's like, man, there's
so much freedom in that.
>> For myself, very similar experience that
way where you're sizing people up and
not not really thinking anything else
about them. You know, somebody just
walks in the room, you're just
immediately sizing them up.
>> So, you're analyzing
>> analyzing all the time. Um, and in
addition to that, I remember
um just almost expecting
that somebody's going to come out of
nowhere
>> and jump me,
>> you know, because you're you're you're
taught you need to be prepared all the
time. Be prepared. I mean, little
details down to like my dad would always
tell me like, don't put your hands in
your pockets.
>> Yeah.
>> Why not?
>> It takes an extra second to get them
out. Not just that, he's like, "I can
show you how I'm gonna how I can break
your arm if your hands are in your
pocket."
>> Oh,
>> yeah. And he would like show like do not
do it, but just show you like the
technique. Like this is what this is all
you have to do. And I mean, you learn
details like this, how many pounds of
pressure it takes to break your arm,
hyperextend your arm, your leg, you
know, your knee,
>> all that kind of stuff. So you
>> it goes much further, like you said,
than just learning like this technique.
you start to learn about the body and
where the nerves are at and the muscles
and how they work and all that. And you
just kind of absorb all that
information. And I remember after
putting all of that aside,
I look back and I was like realizing I
was paranoid
for no reason.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> How many times has somebody come and
jumped you out of nowhere?
>> That's right.
>> How many times
>> have you ever had it any any experience?
>> No. No. And most You know what? It's
funny. You all bring up an interesting
point.
Most martial artists I know have never
had to use it.
>> Yeah.
>> Have never had to use it. And then you
have to ask yourself, well, if you never
had to use it and you spent all this
time
>> training it, what good was it?
>> Yeah.
>> Ultimately,
>> the devil permeates every part of your
life through the martial arts. So like I
would go into a restaurant with my
family.
>> I would never sit with my back facing
the door. You always had a wall behind
your back so that you could see. I mean
every that was just
>> I in church I'm like I'm going to have a
wall behind my back so that nobody can
get beside me or flank me
>> so you can always Now it's like I go in
and I'm like I'll sit down. I don't care
if my back's I'm not worried. Angels of
God are surrounding me. If there's a
danger God will let me know. And it's
like man there's so much freedom with
that. Well, it's also interesting to me
that the first initial thought that you
have walking into a room is like like
how can I either defend or take somebody
out. You know, you think about how like
when you have the training of of of
wanting to witness to people and you
walk into the room and it's like who
here can I like win soul you know it's
like
>> uh it's interesting that that yeah the
devil realizes that you know on God's
side that will permeate every aspect of
your life and if he replaces that and
sort of pacifies that in a different way
>> it's almost like an animal for me it was
like an animal mentality where it's like
I'm on the alert are constantly looking
for danger and there's not.
>> Yeah. And unless you're somebody like me
who trained, I trained at home with my
dad. Unless you're in that kind of a
situation, you spend not just the time
aspect, which all martial artists spend
time. I mean, I used to get up at 6:00
in the morning.
>> Yeah.
>> To train, just practice every day before
school, you know, that kind of stuff.
But beyond that, money.
>> Money.
>> Yes.
>> Lots of money. It's not It's not cheap.
I mean, you could pay I mean, depending
on what era you were in, but you you
pour thousands of dollars
>> into easy.
>> Yeah. Easily thousands of dollars. And
then there's equipment and weapons and,
you know,
things to wear and seminars or you're
going to tournaments or,
>> you know, that kind of thing. So, it's
it becomes it's an investment. Like Eric
said, your whole life essentially
revolves around the martial arts. And
Jesus said, "Where a man puts his money,
that's where where his treasure is,
that's where his heart's going to be."
>> You know, you're you're always on alert.
You're always ready for a confrontation.
>> But as you move forward in your journey
with Christ, you realize that scripture
that a soft answer turns away wrath.
>> Yeah. the humility that's involved in
being able to back down or smile or not
engage in an argument or just humble
yourself, it diffuses
so much tension. And you find that
>> if you allow the Holy Spirit to really
shine through in your life,
confrontations that would normally take
place will not take place.
>> Amen.
>> In addition, when you're in the in the
word,
>> most of the places where conflict takes
place, you don't frequent.
You're not in the bars, you know, you're
not in the places where people who are
prone to get into conflict.
>> You're not there. Your family isn't
there.
>> That's right.
>> So, that takes out what 90 plus% of what
we were training for in the first place.
>> Yeah. The Bible says that no man can
serve two masters. And that that is what
a lot of it boils down to is what master
are you serving? And if your whole life
is invested into the martial arts,
you're not using that time. You're not
using that money to serve God. You're
using it to serve a different master.
And so that's that's one big principle
at play in all of this. I remember
having to ask myself a lot of a lot of
questions before I I met Eric. You know,
is this something I'm going to pass on
to my children? Because when you're a
martial artist, it permeates your whole
your whole life. I mean, you're you're
training you're you're you're training
other people. You're it's just
everything you do almost centers around
that.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, even my clothing was changing.
>> By the time I got to my black belt, I
was predominantly wearing black.
>> Yeah.
>> Almost all the time. My wife thought I
was a gothic person when she met me
>> because it was like black jeans, black
Bruce Lee t-shirt, black leather jacket,
you know, everything is black. My dad
did the same thing. is like he almost
always exclusively wore black and so I
just kind of took that on as part of it
and so it you don't put it down you
don't put it away it's not something
that just goes on the shelf it goes with
you everywhere you go if you are not
practicing
all the time think about the spiritual
implications of that right
>> if you're not practicing all the time
it's not going to do you any good
>> you're going to get to a situation if
you don't know how to form your fist,
you're going to break your hand when you
throw a punch. It's just it's just going
to happen because you're not used to
those movements.
And so, just the same as in
Christianity, if you're not practicing
your faith, if you're not witnessing, if
you're not walking with God all the
time, it's not going to work.
>> That's right.
>> You're either all in or all out.
>> Do you know something that um that I'll
never forget? I remember it was it was
after I had made the first black belt um
under that original grandmaster.
>> Um I wanted to be a teacher one day. I
wanted I wanted to teach. I was like I'm
in this from for life.
>> And he knew that. And even some of the
other people that had been there longer
than I, they they kept telling him,
>> he's the one that you need to get to
take your place because you know you get
to a point where you have to pass on the
mantle.
>> Yep. and he began working with me
because he knew I wanted to teach. I
want to do this for life. I wasn't
worried about money. I just wanted to
teach. And I remember one day there was
a there was a man that had started like
six months prior and he's he's probably
in his late 20s, early 30s. He'd come up
on the wrong side of the tracks.
Probably had big brothers. Uh he'd been
in fights at school. He was just a
fighter. Mhm.
>> didn't have any martial arts training,
but he was just a fighter.
>> And I saw him get promoted to green
belt. And then we had this other guy
that had been there two years that
trained. I mean, four days a week he was
there at the school training and he knew
the techniques. He knew he he did
everything that's required. And I'm
trying to learn how this works. And so I
asked him, I said,
"This guy's been here two years. He's
he's dedicated. He's he's sold out, but
yet you haven't promoted him to green
belt, but this guy over here has only
been here six months, and you've already
promoted him to green belt, and he
doesn't even know the techniques yet.
And I said, I said, you know, and he
knew the the man knew. I wasn't
questioning him. I was trying to
understand why. Why does this work this
way? And he looked at me, he said, that
guy that's been here six months, he
said, he's already got the spirit. He's
already a fighter. We don't have to put
that in him. He's already got that. the
techniques will come. We can teach him
the techniques. He said, "This other
guy, he's not a fighter. The whole
purpose of of punching and kicking and
blocking is to put that spirit in them."
He said, "Because the only way," he
said, in a real life combat situation,
the only way that you can ever defeat an
opponent is if you become more vicious
than they are. And you know it's nice
you make people feel good when you say
hey this is a neat technique but if
their mind is running their technique is
not there they have to be engaged they
have to be there in that moment when
that's happening. And when he said that,
I was like, "Okay, wow.
>> You're talking about something now
that's not simply technique. It's you're
talking about something spiritual has to
change inside of a person."
>> And he said, "Absolutely."
>> You know, along those same uh measures,
I had a teacher, kung fu teacher who
taught the same thing. And the way that
he trained his students, he said,
"Listen, if somebody strikes you and
hits you, you have to come back five
times as hard."
>> Yeah.
>> And that was drilled and drilled and
drilled. So you up the intensity. And
you cannot have a meek and humble
spirit like Christ and yet be training
for fight intensity over and over again.
>> They're polar opposites.
>> That's right. Amen.
>> And my problem was trying to harmonize
the two.
>> Yeah.
>> And justify. So one justification in my
part I say well I'm not going to
practice the bone breaking and the
vicious techniques I'm just going to
practice the iikido style techniques
where I'll subdue through pain.
>> Then after that I said well no that I'll
just subdue through balance manipulation
and control but the key word was still
subdue.
>> Yeah
>> and that's not Christ's method. Mhm.
>> I think what you find is a conflict
between philosophy, and it probably
depends on what level you're at, but
martial arts training and martial arts
philosophy, it was a very striking thing
for me. I remember early on your
training for your your yellow belt
and those first however many lessons,
you're being told
you want to avoid a confrontation. This
is a last resort. You want to do
everything you can to like not hurt the
person, but what are you learning how to
do?
>> Hurt the person.
>> Break their neck.
>> Yeah.
>> Like immediately I'm learning how to
break necks.
>> Yeah.
>> That like if that's what you're training
for, what are you going to do when
you're Yeah.
>> in a confrontation.
>> Mhm.
>> You're not going to be like, "Well, let
me back off because I don't I don't want
to hurt you." Mhm.
>> You're being trained to react to to
respond without thinking. Just
do the do the action. And you're told
you should think about it. You need to,
you know, look over your shoulder, see
who it is, make sure it's not your mom
or something. But the reality is when
you do that over and over and over and
over and over again, what's going to
happen? Muscle memory, right? You're
just going to block. Snap. Done. And
then you have to live with that the
result of that the rest of your life.
>> That's right.
>> Whatever you do. And so it's it's I find
at least I found that martial arts
philosophy and martial arts training
inconsistent.
>> You know, there's a lot of times that
that you see um a lot of Christian
people rectify those two together or try
to blend those two together. But from
what I'm hearing is it's a constant
internal like not rectification.
I mean you're you're not you're not able
to make those two kind of work together
is what I'm hearing.
>> It's very difficult to try to harmonize
it. I remember one of the hardest
questions I had to to answer. All right.
I had um a number of friends who trained
in Brazilian jiu-jitsu. All right. good
guys and they had the ability to control
a person, take them down, subdue so that
they don't do any harm.
>> Mhm.
>> And they say, "Listen, what would be the
issue if I'm training for that?" And you
know, there are people who have helped
other people, you know, using that. For
me, and I'm not speaking for any of
them, for me,
the determining factor for avoiding or
or leaving behind my marshall training
was the mindset that it developed. I
don't care how much I told myself, you
know, you can avoid that. Great people,
nice people.
>> Yeah.
>> But, you know, if they had to turn it
on, they could do it easy. M
>> I found that
when Christ
gives his spirit, the fruits of the
spirit become more manifest.
>> Love, joy, peace, longsuffering,
gentleness, goodness, faith, humility.
>> And
>> that fruit
>> is not shown in dominance.
>> That's right. And so I always have to
come back to the most important thing
for me was the destruction of the
mindset.
>> Um and I could not even when I was was
in that I can't
embrace the fruit while practicing
strangulation.
>> Yeah.
>> Or cranking an arm.
>> Interesting.
>> That's my my my perspective.
>> Good point. Good point. 2 Corinthians
chapter 10 um verse 4 it says for the
weapons of our warfare
>> are not carnal but mighty in God for
pulling down strongholds casting down
arguments and every high thing that
exalts itself against the knowledge of
God bringing every thought like you said
into the captivity of obedience of
Christ and being ready to punish all
disobedience when your obedience is
fulfilled. So
with me, what I had to do is like like
each of you, I had to come to this place
where I said,
"We're in a war.
We're all in a war, right?
>> What kind of conflict are we preparing
for?
>> Are we preparing for the physical
conflict or are we preparing for the
spiritual conflict?"
>> Amen. And according to the Bible,
there's one that's a whole lot more
important, and that's the spiritual
conflict.
>> So, you can spend all this time in
martial arts, and you're essentially
training for the wrong conflict, the
wrong war.
>> Amen.
>> And so, if I'm going to essentially win,
right? And I can only win through the
power of Christ because he's the one
that's won. But if I'm going to be on
the right side of the conflict, I'm
going to be on the right side of the
war, then I have to train the right way.
>> Amen.
>> And the way I have to train is different
than the way I was training before.
Because what are you going to do at the
end of time when everything is crazy,
everything is going down. We we see it
now. The people are polarized. They're
angry. They're going to shoot you if
they don't agree with you.
You're no match for a bullet and you're
no match for a military,
>> right?
>> And what are you going to do if somebody
disagrees with you and and now a
confrontation? Are you going to say I'm
going to fight you
>> because I'm on God's side?
>> Is that going to show them Jesus?
>> No.
>> Yeah. No.
>> And that for me was the determining
factor is like how do I show people
Christ? It's never going to happen if I
continue to train in the martial arts
because my natural reaction will be to
hurt you, not to help you. It's like
Peter.
>> Amen.
>> I'm going to bust out a knife. I'm going
to cut the guy's ear off.
>> Yeah.
>> And we're going to go. We're going to
go. I'm going to defend. Right.
>> But I love it. Yeah. I love it that
Jesus like demonstrates right there.
This is not what this is about.
>> Like like
>> he puts the guy's ear back on. I want to
know what put your sword away. What did
that guy do at that moment? Was he just
like, "Okay, guys, let's just keep going
here. It's better."
>> Yeah. You had to be shook.
>> Yeah. You I mean, would you not be like,
"Maybe we should not be here, guys.
Seriously, like this is not the right
way to do this,
>> right?"
>> But yeah, it's like violence has never
been
>> And Jesus himself, you know, he said,
"My kingdom is not of this world." He
told people like he said, "You know, if
I needed
12,000
>> Yeah.
>> You know,
>> I could ask and it would be here
instantly.
>> I have it."
>> Mhm.
>> But he's he didn't ask for it
>> because he was also fighting a battle
and he knew the only way to win that
battle was to submit to his father.
>> You know, something I remember, you
know, like you were talking about, I
know Keith has went through this. um
you know when when when you walk away
from it, there's still questions. The
enemy brings questions. Sometimes you
have questions of your own mind.
>> And so I was still looking for answers.
And
um the Lord led me to find a couple of
testimonies from other men that had been
involved in martial arts longer than I
had. And one of the testimonies was from
a a Chinese man. Uh he's an architect. I
think he's still probably alive. But he
told a story. He said, you know, he had
trained under a grandmaster for years
and years, had developed all kinds of
power. I mean, fighting, he could fight
physically. This wasn't point sparring.
And
he said when when the Lord called him
out of it, he said, "I remember I was I
was doing evangelism in Hong Kong and I
had two other like deacons or elders
that were with me and we were in the in
this taxi cab and we're driving through
this rough part of Hong Kong and
he said we pulled up, you know, where we
had to stop and he said, you know,
immediately I sensed, you know, there's
there's danger." And he said, "I looked
out one window and I saw these two guys
walking towards me. And I look out this
other window and this guy's walking
towards the car." And he said, you know,
instantly I was like, "Okay, there's a
problem here." And
the guy that was coming on this side,
you know, his window was down because
they didn't have, I guess, AC. And he
said he put a gun right to his head. And
the two guys that were with him that
were in ministry, both of them said
afterward, they were like, "We knew this
guy's going to kill him." I mean, you
know, the
>> the the one that had been in the martial
arts, this is over. He's going to take
that guy out immediately. And he said it
flashed through his mind the technique,
what to do, how to take this gun away
from this guy. And he said, and then all
of a sudden, he said he heard the voice
of the Lord Jesus Christ. And the Lord
said, "Do you trust me?"
And the man's name was Paul Wong. And
Paul said, "I trust you." And he said,
instantly, he said, "The spirit of God
came upon me and he said, I turned and
put my face right into the gun." And he
looked at the man and he said, "In the
name of Jesus Christ, get off of me."
And he said, the man literally was
picked up and thrown backwards like in
the air
>> off the ground. He was picked up and
thrown backwards a number of feet away.
And then later the police actually
apprehended him, caught him, arrested
him. And the man said, when they asked
him what happened, he said, "I literally
felt a hand or two hands grab the back
of my clothing and pick me up off the
off the ground and throw me backwards."
>> Wow. And when I read that, it was like
it was exactly what I needed to hear
because you know the Bible and I had and
to interject that I had my stepfather
who I love him. He's a god-fearing man.
I remember one time my wife and children
and my my mom were out. They all went
out shopping or something on a Sunday
and me and my stepfather were there at
the house and he told me he said, "You
know, Eric, we're here by oursel." He
said, "I just want to ask you some
questions." And we he knew what I'd went
through.
>> But he said um he said, "Eric, I know
you came out of the martial arts." He
said, "But I want to ask you." He said,
"If somebody broke into your house
tonight, two men, three men, and they
were going to hurt your wife and
children." He said, "You'd use what you
trained what you know to do." And it was
like, as soon as he started asking the
questions, I was praying because he
knows the Lord, but I was like, "Lord, I
need your answer, not my answer." And it
was instantly the Lord told me, turn to
Psalms 34:7
and I I opened up my Bible and I looked
at him and I said, you know, to my
stepfather, I said, I know you believe
God's word, don't you? And he said, of
course. And I said, read that verse. Do
you believe what that says? It says,
"The angel of the Lord encamps round
about them that fear him and delivers
them because we trust in him." And my my
stepfather read that and he looked at me
and he said,"I
can't argue with you." And I said, 'I
don't have to worry about defending my
wife and children. I'm not saying I
wouldn't, right?
>> But I don't have to think preemptively
about that because what I do is is every
single moment I have no idea what's
going to happen every moment. Yeah. But
the spirit of God that's in me and in
living in me, the Holy Spirit will tell
me, Eric, you need to do such and such,
or you need to move your children and
your wife over here, or you need to take
that that road instead of this road. I
don't have to train for that.
>> And it was like, there's so much freedom
now.
>> You don't have to worry about that.
>> What you're saying is so important for
people to hear because that very
question I was asked several months ago.
You want to know my honest answer?
>> When I was asked that question, it was
the very same one. If someone were
standing over your wife, what would you
do? My answer was, and I'm thinking
about how much I love my wife. I'm going
to introduce him to eight friends,
>> two hands, two elbows, two knees, two
feet.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. That's thinking in the carnal.
>> Yeah.
>> That's reverting back to the
selfdefense,
>> the flesh. Yeah.
>> The flesh.
Since then,
it's so important that you mention that.
I adopted that same mindset because I
was going through the scriptures saying,
"Wait a minute, the Lord is the
defender."
>> Amen.
>> There is no self-defense in Christianity
because he will lead you through that.
Um, I'm so glad you said it because so
many of our martial arts friends are
confronted with that thought process and
those situations. Matter of fact, a lot
of it fuels their training because they
want to defend themselves and the people
they love.
>> That's right.
>> And so you ask a question like that,
this is why I train so that I can keep
them safe. And then I used to say, well,
I'm provider, protector, and priest.
protection goes beyond the physical. As
you said, we have to train for the right
war.
>> Amen.
>> And our weapons are different. They're
not physical.
>> Amen.
>> And I think um that is a critical piece
for our what I would call our struggling
martial arts family to know and to
understand.
And
>> there's a question I like to ask people
about that. I think it helps them think
through the situation.
If you train in the martial arts, will
God protect you more or less?
>> Amen.
>> Come on.
Come on.
>> And and I think people understand when
when they're asked that question, it's
like, okay, well, God's God's protection
is not dependent on my training. Right.
>> That's right.
>> He doesn't love me less and he's not
>> doesn't love you less. And it's it's not
like God is saying, "Well, I'll protect
you more if you don't train in the
martial arts and he's not going to
protect you less the other way." So if
God's protection and and then the second
question to that is whose protection is
better?
>> The one that you can provide or the one
that he can provide?
>> Amen. So then if you think through both
of those questions, you come to the
conclusion that like well God's
protection is better and he's going to
protect me then what do I need to worry
about? And I I think ultimately where
we're faced with human beings is we have
this we have a fear in the back of our
mind that God will not hold up his end
of the bargain. And
you know that we will be left bruised,
broken, and bleeding.
And we don't know what to do about that.
And so because we don't know what to do
about that, we try to help God out.
>> Yeah. and we say, "Well, just in case
God doesn't hold up his end of the
bargain,
>> I'm going to train in the martial arts."
And we're not sitting here, I mean, I I
think I can agree that we're we're not
sitting here like saying,
"Well, just be stupid." We're not here
to say, "Be stupid.
>> You don't put yourself in compromising
situations."
We're not saying that you shouldn't
help your family if they were under
duress or or being
attacked. God forbid, right?
>> Right.
>> You would you would put yourself in
between somebody in your family. Anybody
would do that. But you don't have to
you don't have to worry about it. You
don't you don't sit around all the time
wondering, "Is God gonna provide my
food? Is God going to provide my
clothing? Is God going to provide all
these other things? Then why would we
worry about that? Do
>> you know it's interesting because like
the Bible says, "Put ye on the Lord
Jesus Christ and make not provision for
the flesh." When you look up the word
provision, and I'm going to put this in
modern English, it means don't buy an
insurance policy in case of failure.
>> Don't make provision just in case.
>> And God's not making a bargain with us.
Like Keith said, you know, is he going
to hold up his end of the bargain?
There's no bargain. God has made
promises to us. He wants us to believe
him. And I thought about that. I was
like, I don't want to walk on a level
one. I want to walk like Enoch walked. I
want to walk like Elijah and Elisha. And
I want to walk in the Holy Spirit. And
if we do that,
God will always fulfill his promises to
us.
>> Yeah. I think that, you know, um
something that stuck with me that I
remember the conversation when we
started doing the Dragon Revealed was um
if you don't have any training
whatsoever and you get into an
altercation, you are put in a position
where um Lord, it's in your hands. And
that's a good position to be in.
>> Amen.
>> To be like, you know, I don't know what
the outcome of this this is going to be,
and I'm going to trust, Lord, that
you're going to help me out in this
situation. And and I I think as I'm
listening to this, I mean, not having
any sort of training whatsoever, it's
like I hear, you know, that that that
just trigger um you know, mode that
you're going to go into. You're just
going to revert to, you know, you've
you've done this so many times and the
goal of martial arts from what I'm
hearing is to react without needing to
think about it. Mh.
>> And so it's like if that's your mode
that you're in, um, you know, you do put
yourself in a different position when
you when you have zero training
whatsoever. And it's like, Lord, however
this outcome happens is is it's going to
be in your hands.
>> Amen.
>> So, it seems like it's a matter of
faith. Do we trust God or not? And if we
don't believe like you were saying Keith
that God is going to fully take care of
us then we feel we have to do it
ourselves. You know I I heard the story
actually
someone that I knew told me about this
and I really made I I made a spiritual
correlation
and there was this person who was about
to get into an altercation with someone
else. Now person um was a was a friend
of a friend and he said to the aggressor
>> who was ready to to engage
>> he said listen um if we engage you're
going to hit me probably knock me down
and I'm going to bleed and going to be
hurt and what's going to happen to you
I'm going to press charges
and you're going to go to jail because I
will see this through and I'm not going
to fight back.
You're going to lose your job, going to
lose your freedom,
and you're going to lose a lot more than
you're going to gain from hitting me. Do
you really want to do this? And you know
what that guy was doing? He was trusting
in a higher power, the government.
>> And he was trusting the law
>> to defend him.
>> And I said, well, let's let's take that
a step further. He was exhibiting faith.
>> Mhm.
>> He felt it would be detrimental to fight
back because he knew what the law was
going to do to the aggressor. How much
more so, Father?
>> Amen.
>> So, when people in the world can exhibit
that kind of faith, then it puts it in a
new light
>> and it taught me a lesson. Amen.
>> I don't need to fight
for anything. You know, something that
Keith brought up about um about the
warfare. There's two wars. Either
there's a physical or there's a
spiritual. And the Bible says we don't
wrestle against flesh and blood. Right.
>> We don't wrestle against our own flesh
and blood. That means an aggressor. I'm
not wrestling against flesh and blood.
The aggressor is being influenced by
something.
>> That's right.
>> Either they're being influenced by God
or they're being influenced by the devil
or an evil spirit.
So, if I realize that what I'm battling
is not this person in front of me, maybe
the guy got in a fight with his wife,
maybe he lost his job yesterday, maybe
we have no idea what's going on in this
person's life,
I'm dealing with what I see, but I need
to say, Lord, I need your eyesight. If
this person is hurting and they're
lashing out because of I need that's
what Jesus that's how Jesus dealt with
things. And I remember, and this was a
true story, I remember reading about
this lady. She got into her car one
night. True story. And when she got into
her car, she sat down, put her keys in,
and she felt a hand come up around her
throat.
And this man was waiting for her in the
car.
>> And he grabs her and he tells her, "This
is where we're going to go. I want you
to drive." And he drives her way outside
of town at nighttime.
And you know what's going through this
woman's mind? I I'm going to be raped.
I'm maybe I'm going to be murdered. This
is not good. She had no training. She
had no ability.
>> She had nobody she could call. She's
she's in trouble. And she said she
started praying to God.
>> And I'm I'm thinking like Keith said,
"Okay, if there's two different sides
here, which battle do I want to train
for? I need to be fighting the fight of
faith now so that we can stand when it
really matters.
>> Yeah.
>> This lady starts talking by the power of
the Holy Spirit, she starts talking to
the the man who's taken her out to rape
her and kill her.
By time they get out to where he was
going to take her,
he is in the front seat and he's in
tears and she is sharing Jesus. She's
sharing the gospel with him.
>> Wow. Do you know what happens?
He asks her to take her to the jail and
to let him turn himself in. And then she
starts coming to the jail to the prison
where he is and continues giving Bible
studies to him and sharing food with
him. And that man's going to be in
heaven.
>> A different kind of war.
>> And because she believed, she had no one
to turn to but God. And she trusted him.
>> Yes. And God did the un He did the
impossible. And that's the God I want to
serve.
>> Amen.
>> That's the kind of defense that I want.
>> Because there's no way you can plan for
that. There's no way you can train for
that.
>> Amen.
>> And not only was she victorious in
escaping danger, but a soul or or a
brand was plucked from the fire.
>> Amen. So the real enemy behind working
through him was defeated soundly.
>> Amen.
>> Amazing.